well the race is here I see with several
AI experts is that they they think they
know more than they do and they think
they're smarter than the action bar but
I'm very close to the cutting edge in AI
and it scares the hell out of me
it's capable of vastly more than almost
anyone knows and the rate of improvement
is exponential but we have to figure out
some way to ensure that the advent of
digital super intelligence is one which
is a symbiotic with humanity I think
that's the single biggest existential
crisis that we face and the most
pressing one mark my words
AI is far more dangerous the news for
depending on which study you read in the
next few decades humanity will reach the
singularity the point at which computers
will match or exceed human intelligence
or in other words when humanity might
become obsolete now whether or not you
lean towards the optimistic side of
things or the dystopian side of future
you gotta wonder where would that leave
humans
[Music]
this video was made possible with the
help of the awesome guys at Skillshare
get your free two-month premium
membership to over 25,000 classes and
business entrepreneurship and tech with
the first link in the video description
[Music]
if you think about it all humanity has
ever achieved has been because of these
three factors how much information we
can take in or how fast we can read and
how fast we can move our eyes how fast
we can process information in our heads
and how much information we can put out
how fast can we write talk type and
swipe left and every problem we haven't
solved yet curing cancer going to Mars
whatever other issues Millennials are
supposed to care about really all comes
back to how fast or how slow flat matter
we can interact or interface with the
world around us based on those three
factors we don't really have a problem
with how fast we can process information
our brains are pretty quick but the real
bottleneck are the first and third
factors how fast can we take information
in and how fast we can output
information to the outside world
compare that to artificial intelligence
when it reaches its singularity point it
would be able to think like us and
process information like us except it
won't have the bottleneck of ten fingers
two eyeballs aging and disease or in
other words our brains have the
potential to keep up with AI but
humanity's interface with the world our
senses and physical bodies or severely
handicapped or have very low bandwidth
as Elan likes to call it so hopefully we
can have a tertiary layer which is the
kind of a digital super intelligence
layer and in fact you already have this
layer so it's your phone and your laptop
and the constraint is just how well you
interface the the input and output speed
the obvious feat is especially slow
since most people typing with thumbs
these days so you have a very slow
output speed your input speed as much
fast to do to vision but the thing that
will ultimately constrain our ability to
be somatic with AI is bandwidth and as
AI gets closer and closer to that
singularity point humans will just keep
falling further and further back but I
think even in a benign AI scenario we
will be left behind so we have the super
intelligent blob in between our ears
computers that can help augment what we
can accomplish
but then
we have these primitive archaic limbs
connecting the two together well gee if
only there was a way to increase our
bandwidth from our brains to computers
if there was we could solve this
bottleneck problem and not only be on
par with computers when real AI hits but
maybe even read alongside it in 2017
Elon launched a very secretive Sarco
neuro link to hopefully prevent his
dystopian visions from coming true
essentially normal link is in the
business of turning people into textbook
definition cyborgs with what's called
brain machine interface devices or BM
eyes where one day you can walk into a
neuro-link storefront maybe you will be
like Tesla stores and malls today and
instead of having an all-out brain
surgery where you're put to sleep
they're drilling into your head and
poking around your brain it would be as
non-evasive as something like LASIK
surgery where you're in and out once you
have the BMI installed it would connect
wirelessly to an outside of wearable so
you don't have to have wires sticking
out of your head and of course you'll be
able to control your new cyborg
abilities via a smartphone app from
there unlike plows I have to touch their
smartphone screen you can just think
about touching it and it will have the
same effects instead of limiting
yourself to how fast and accurately your
fingers can move on a keyboard you could
just think about what the type or think
where to move your mouse and the
computer would treat your thoughts just
like any other USB keyboard or mouse I
can already visualize the trevor wallace
videos coming but it doesn't stop at
just being able to operate a keyboard or
mouse even though let's be honest that's
probably what I'm most excited about so
I can just edit videos like this by just
thinking about it but aside from that
the applications type platform like this
will provide or much further reaching to
say the least one of the most impactful
ways that this tech will help us right
away is with curing brain diseases and
disorders which is where neuro-link is
focusing on first other applications
include helping the blind see speech
language allowing people with
disabilities to touch and feel and as
crazy as it sounds it could even offer a
form of telepathy in the future
Elon refers to AI as the biggest
existential threat to human
future but with something like this as
the technology progresses knurling
offers us not just a way outs but a way
in to ride the wave of real AI instead
of being crushed by Skynet like many
other revolutions of the past it's
really hard to comprehend what kind of
problems would be it would solve and
what problems we'll create with this new
technology a lot of people talk about
how revolutionary AI is blockchain even
me with quantum computing but if you
think about it all those innovations
operate outside of humans it's just
another tool that we interact with but
brain machine interfaces we're talking
about the first invention that truly
evolved humans as a species and just
like Tesla in the early days a neural
link are one of the very few pioneers
that have this brand new industry all to
themselves and who knows maybe they'll
look back and call this era the cyborg
revolution
[Music]
now Elan and neural Inc have made some
bold claims I mean come on telepathy is
he smoking again
communicating what the brain via a
computer may sound like far-off science
fiction but how neural Lake and others
in the neural engineering field in the
past have been able to achieve this is
actually surprisingly simple not easy
but simple you may know that our brains
are really just a bunch of neurons
connected together all of your
experiences memories happiness sadness
is all a result of nearly a hundred
billion neurons working together and the
way they work together is through
electrical spikes these electrical
spikes trigger more electrical spikes to
the neurons they're connected to and
much like how complex modern day
computers and smartphones all break down
into simple ones and zeros like we
talked about in the quantum computing
gold rush video this thing happening
right now called your life all break
down to the simple electrical impulses
happening right now between your ears
you're able to move a mouse because of
the specific group of neurons spiking
together in your brain you're able to
see this video because the specific
photons hitting your eyes causes your
brain to fire spikes in a specific group
of neurons in a specific way
this is why something like neural link
is possible because our brains in a way
function via the same medium that
computers use electricity and if we're
able to create machines that can read
and create these electrical spikes we
can connect our brains with the outside
world the same way our physical bodies
do but with a computer to achieve this
neural link invented the rest the size
of neurons that can be implanted in
specific areas of the brain that we want
to interface with these threads have
electrodes on the ends that can detect
and create the electrical spikes the
neurons to use to communicate once the
spikes are detected around a group of
neurons and that information is then
sent to a compared to be translated into
computer language that we can make sense
of we're thinking about keeping a mouse
cursor still the neurons that the
electrodes are monitoring fire in a
pattern that might look like this well
you're thinking about moving a mouse
cursor up those neurons might fire in a
pattern like this and we're thinking
about moving a mouse cursor down those
neurons might fire in a pattern like
this do the same thing to record
left to right and now you have a brain
machine interface that knows how to
control a computer mouse and just by
monitoring your thoughts that are
represented by electrical spikes in your
brain and processing that in a computer
to do whatever you want or in other
words you are now a cyborg and if you
want to use be a mice to do any of the
other things we talked about you just do
the exact same thing except you would
implant these electrodes on different
parts of the brain that control the
specific function you're going after
which of course includes areas
responsible for speech to use for
telepathy and for the most part that's
pretty much the general idea behind
brain machine interfaces and if you were
to get one installed again following
neural links goal of keeping it as
non-evasive as possible here is how it
would go in the future
down to the injection of local
anesthetic a very small opening on the
skin a painless opening in the skull
below quick and precise placement of
threads into the cortex and then we fill
that hole in the skull with the sensor
allowing the scalp to be closed up over
it behind the ear we'll make a small
incision to insert the coil we will
tunnel tiny wires under the scalp to
connect the sensors to the coil that's
the process
[Music]
unfortunately it's not all sunshine and
rainbows though as much as I would love
to have one of these installed in me
right now and be a guinea pig it's gonna
take a while
anything related to medicine and health
are littered with regulations FDA
approval and other hoops to jump through
that are important bar still really
inefficient and with the recent
crackdown and pressure from the US
government on the big tech giants
especially with the response to
Facebook's Libra cryptocurrency I
wouldn't be terribly surprised if there
are Senate hearings over these
brain-machine interfaces in the future
on top of that there are so many
engineering hurdles from the neuro-link
team to get through especially in the
material science department in fact a
lot of this footage that you see in this
video is from their launch event that
they host back in mid 2019 we're at Elon
stated that the sole purpose of this
event was to recruit more talent when
Elon contacted me over two and a half
years ago now and told me about his
vision for the company I knew that I
wanted to join for these two reasons
because I knew that the technology was
at a point where with the right team and
the right the right vision and a
long-term vision we could do the sorts
of things that we're talking about and I
knew that with that team we could do
things that no one had even dreamed
about yet there was nothing on the
market or in laughs that fit their needs
so they had to create all of this
themselves so what they've achieved in
just two years is pretty incredible
they already have the first human
product that they're testing called n1
they've had to invent the robot that
implants all the electrodes with extreme
accuracy into the brains of mice and
monkeys and they're optimistic goal for
the first human clinical trials are for
late this year and at first I'll only be
focusing on people with diseases and
disorders that could benefit most from
n1 and very slowly they'll bring it out
to the broader public but the hurdles
unfortunately don't end there neural
link is well aware of the dangers of
privacy in hacking but we're still a
long ways away and there are still many
questions that we haven't even thought
about asking you so there is a very long
road ahead of us but even with those
concerns and roadblocks can we just take
a moment to appreciate that we live in a
world where you can solve in
prehensile II big problems like the
number one threat to me Mandy with a
start-up I don't know about you but that
is pretty beautiful
so Ilan max if you're watching this
unfortunately I don't have any horrible
diseases or disabilities of a man I
would love to be a part of your clinical
trials sign into my DMS and hurry up and
take my money please
take it but until that day arrives where
you can augment your brain why not
improve your brain with a few of the
25,000 plus classes over on Skillshare
why does every creator seem to be
sponsored by Skillshare it's because
their stuff is pretty awesome and they
make content like this easier for
creators like me to create you probably
already know what Skillshare is but if
you don't it's an online learning
community where for less than $10 a
month you get access to over 25,000
classes from experts and creators on
every topic you can imagine including
business entrepreneurship coding and
much more and now you understand that
one of humanity's biggest bottlenecks
right now is how fast we can input and
output information I highly recommend
you check out some of the Metta living
classes men are learning is probably one
of the most important things that they
should have taught you in school but
they did it and that's learning how to
learn and as you know we have a pretty
capable machine in between our ears yet
no one taught us how to use it and a
great place to start improving your IO
speed is with the tried and true
productivity masterclass by Thomas Frank
where the entire class is literally
about improving how fast you can take in
and output information to the world
around you I've already started
implementing stuff from it and man it is
really good so if you want to get ahead
before les singularity comes and support
this channel you can check out
productivity master class but they free
two month premium membership on
Skillshare with the first link in the
video description so thank you so much
for being part of the watch to the end
Club and if you are new to this channel
I analyze past and future businesses
just like this video and hopefully
visually and audio Li pleasing way so if
you enjoyed please consider subscribing
and turning on a notification bell that
is unfortunately all the shameless plugs
I have you today thank you so much for
watching you've been awesome
I've been Jake and I will see you guys
in the next one
[Music]